hey
hi i need to take a bathroom break just
stay here for a minute
uh-huh what did you ask what that
panel's for
no oh yeah don't worry about that panel
just stay here i'll be right back
and don't touch anything
hi my name is markiplier and welcome to
please don't touch anything
this is a game where i'm going to touch
everything everything possible
i last played this game a while ago
lexie and play a clip of me playing that
game wherever the hell you are
just stay here i'll be right back and
don't touch
anything you know i always love it when
people say the name of the game in the
dialogue that they're talking oh boink
oh damn it i missed the button right off
the bat
now this is the 3d version of it it
doesn't need to be played in vr
but i have vr and i like vr okay
so i have hands
i don't know if this is exactly meant to
be used with this
grab your screwdriver grab your hammer
work blah blah blah
one one one two one one two one one
hey okay i'm back great thanks
you really helped me sorry it took so
long
what's the matter worried something
might happen really
like what the apocalypse you've got to
have an education to run this machine
[Music]
ah let's go
go where hang on i was introducing
everything i need to master my equations
and whatever the hell that is
[Music]
feels like baldi's basics in here all
right
can i no three seven zero zero whatever
that equation is
joshua three one one three nine nine two
three six four
well it's one of those puzzly games and
i'm
decent puzzles so this game actually
came out a little bit ago
but i didn't play it when it first came
out for one reason or another
i really enjoyed the first one i don't
know why it took me so long to play this
one
but play i shall
what does this button do bump
does it do nothing i don't know
maybe i resent it oh what did i do
oh well this appeared out of nowhere
there oh i don't know what i did
what did i did
[Music]
oh oh no oh no oh no
uh whoa
i'm probably not good
how do i un undo that
[Music]
three two one three two one what
i forgot that that was the whole thing
about the first game is that i
accidentally blew up everything by
touching things
oh okay well that's probably not
great
um i love my oh i get
it i got the first ending by being doing
nothing i see
okay boink so what do i do
[Music]
okay so that definitely did the whole
apocalypse thing
okay so that ah i see
so that did the same thing there right
that was the whole crux of this game
wait a minute where's the screwdriver
i wonder if i get a reward for this damn
it
hey thanks for picking up all that trash
the station director would fire me on
the spot if she saw what a mess this
place was
okay i'll be back in a minute thank you
do i get something for that i get
something for that right
oh yeah oh yeah
i'm the best okay so there are things
that i can do around in the area
i'm just not 100 sure what they might be
i don't know if i could look in that
hole hello
hello no okay i'm a little closer than
i'd like to be
[Music]
boink okay so don't touch that thing
wait what's this to the right oh
oh oh i gotta caress it
[Music]
come on oh there you are okay okay
there you are interesting
what is this oh it's one of these oh
it's one of these
um
damn it oop
[Music]
bam got it i'm the best what did i do
um oh
why is there oh
why is there so much power in this one
facility why would anyone give anyone
this much power
why why should anyone have this amount
of power this seems egregious
all right hey oh i played this game
solar smash
hey hey oh i cracked the whole planet in
half
oh well that seems oddly excessive what
else
fiddle diddly what else what other
fiddly diddly things do we have
what other fiddle-dee diddle-dee what
other fiddle-dee-doo
oh there we go oh
two two three two
one two oh wait wait wait three one two
two
three one two two one
one okay star
that
ah three one two two one three three one
two two one three
three one two two one
three oh don't do it don't do what
what am i doing oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait one
no huh
oh what is this
is any of this real um
wow way out what is tps report i don't
know whoa
whoa fibonacci whoa three
touch everything three one two one oh my
god oh my god
wow this is a lot of secrets and puzzles
okay um kind of unsure about all this
blood and whatnot and
yep wish i could wish i had photogenic
photo photogenic memories where are you
oh no did i just sorry
sorry all right so i accidentally um
cr
[Music]
correct correct click correct
correct correct three one oh morse
oh mo morse morse oh morse right
yeah here we go at least i don't have to
remember it
okay dni you got it
[Music]
what did i do
oh oh
huh well sorry everybody it's waterworld
now
would that have flooded me if i'd have
waited all right well that was fun
okay cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
can i just keep pressing it whoa hammer
hammer
i got a screwdriver oh
oh 911
uh i'm dying i'm i'm
i'm dying hello i'm dying okay
um okay uh how about three one one no
go away three one one
three nine nine three nine
nine two three six four
two three six four
hello joshua
hello
well that's a dial-up tone
[Music]
what
hello
okay was that helpful
hello okay city boom
i don't know where that goes crash crash
bam boom bang
boom bang
how about the screwy driver
okay well that's a thing now okay well
i'm getting a lot of things
but i'm not getting a lot of answers but
there's a code there
red red blue red blue blue
red red blue red oh
invalid oh it's a four code
red green red green blue
[Music]
i could just brute force this several
brute force attempts later
oh oh oh i did it what are you
wings what are you what are you what is
that
what is that what is that what is that
what am i looking at
what are you what are you what are you
supposed to be
what are you what are you supposed to be
what are you supposed to be let me try
open up
three one two two one
three okay so that's open is this dugan
that opens that okay so now i've got a
number sequence here
numpad april 3rd 2021
april 3rd 2021 0403 0403 2021
00403 two oh it's just
wait oh i remember three one
two one damn it what a one two one one
one two one one three seven oh
oh numbers numbers numbers kind of
strange
maybe because i tried to brute force it
it decided to lock me
out of it what if i do
how about these yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh oh oh
hey oh hi
can you push that button for me can you
push that button
hey could you push that button for me
right there that one right there
can you push that button yeah you want
me to show you how
can you push the button what
what happened what happened
but i just what
what did i what did i do
what
[Music]
what dummy
dummy dummy you're a dummy ah
that's when the extra buttons began to
appear
what the frick what what
what and then more buttons what
stanley parable and then
more buttons wow you know i'm not
opposed to this this is pretty cool
i like it i'm not opposed to it
until at last there were so many buttons
to press that stanley wasn't sure
he could press them all stanley stanley
i pressed them all
and then he did and then i did
[Music]
yeah oh man it's been forever since i
played stanley parable
oh hell yeah oh
oh god what a game
what a strange game what a bizarre
strange game that was
god i'm not i'm nowhere close to beating
this it's going very slowly
i don't even know what prompted that
probably just one of those random things
where time
just causes it to happen let me go this
way again
so i got that open let me go ahead and
get this color panel open can i please
can i
thank you
no no no there we go no
no no no no no no there we go okay so i
got colors
i got that there's got to be something
about the unless that actually was
the pattern that was the pattern but why
did that close up
so that was the pattern but i just
accidentally got it
oh 8267 apparently
[Music]
oh 3-1-21
stop trying to grab skip oh my god
there we go what happened
[Music]
oh
okay so there's some kind of a musical
sequence going on here where was our
music
[Music]
there wait wait wait wait
ho ho
oh my god
[Music]
oh i'm a god
i'm a god amongst mere mortals don't
even
think about challenging me i'm
unstoppable
in every way i know things that was
awesome
very happy about that which way did i go
for that yeah this way
come here you where were you eight two
six seven eight two
six seven okay then this opened up
oh my god there's no way
oh there is no way
oh no
wait what was the thing about the thing
and the thing and the thing wasn't there
something there
with this thing you
[Music]
right can i have this no okay so if i
look at that that way
bottom left top left top left bottom
left
oh
holy
uh you're welcome everybody
well good for me what is this supposed
to be what is that supposed to be
it doesn't look like no saucer i ever
seen okay cool
god damn this is so many endings there's
no way that i'm gonna be able to get
this all in one video
but i am enjoying the hell out of this
it is supremely interesting to me
this is fascinating to me grab your
screwdriver
grab your hammer grip your hammer
there's two step
fours one two four four
[Music]
oh ooh ooh
oh whoa
oh
okay well that's normal yeah it's very
normal um
nothing i should be worried about
definitely uh
yeah all right i'll just get out of here
okay black hole cool
man i whoa what what what
what is with you what is with you what
do i do about that
what do i do about that there's got to
be something to do about that it wants
my papers
so get papers please huh the stamp the
stick
the stick the stint the stamp the stamp
high
oh my god hi
denied sorry dude oh
[Music]
oh oh oh
oh oh
oh lord
god thank goodness i played that game
finally holy crap
okay let's go right this time i still
got that
bender bender rodriguez
four four
four four four oh what
what is that what is that
what is that is that a keyhole can i
pick it
no but that's a key hole okay
there's a keyhole now good god how many
puzzles
are there how many goddamn puzzles are
there this is insane
okay so there's got to be a key here
somewhere there's also got to be a place
to put that in
there's also got to be something else to
go with here that number is still there
so there's got to be something else for
that
three one two two one one was not a
thing right
two two one one that's not one
but maybe there's others there was like
five five oh headset power's low ah look
i'm
busy uh oh one one no that wouldn't be
it that's his fibonacci
study i know i know i know i know
i know 8020
that is definitely a thing eight zero
two there a zero two zero
right wait what is that is zero two zero
eight zero two zero that's definitely a
thing eight zero two zero
where could i put that in phone
[Music]
nah there was numbers somewhere but i
don't think i can get them anymore
let's let's take a close look at
everything
there might be something here that i
don't know about
i've ever said touch everything yeah i'm
working on it
touch everything i want to
touch you touch everything i'm gonna
touch
everything oh i can erase
oh god that's cool
interesting very interesting
let me look at this
[Music]
that's pretty cool
and a boop well i'm very happy about
that touching touching touching touching
touching everything
my headset's gonna run out of power
touching touching touching
screws screws no i've tried those before
they didn't work
touch everything touch everything what
about over here touch touch touch
touch touch touch touch touch touch
touch everything
[Music]
hey and i'm way away from where i should
be hey
how's it going gang hey all right so my
headset's about to die but
this game is very fun okay i love a good
puzzle
and this is just like really satisfying
to be able to solve
unfortunately it seems like i can't
solve it all in one video i'm not gonna
look any spoilers
don't tell me anything in the comments
below i'm gonna figure this out and i'm
gonna do another video about this and
i'm gonna get them all
i'm gonna get them all by myself don't
tell me a goddamn thing okay cool
wait a minute there's something over
[Music]
there
no